vous trouvez pas ça bizarre que votre
matériel de travail de tous les jours
soit dans un musée maintenant pas du
tout
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
métier qui peut renaître non je crois
pas
certaines plaques des rues de Dijon
raconte l'histoire de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les petits métiers où en sont
ces petits métiers que sont devenus ces
artisans à la vie difficile mais pris de
leur liberté à Dijon cherche
désespérément une remailleuse tricoteuse
repasseuse modiste ou chapelière de bois
corsetière nous avons rencontré les
derniers la mode le progrès a
définitivement fermé leur boutique
est-ce que c'est encore un métier très
doute ça plus un métier parce qu'elle
gagne environ
si on gagne pas d'argent c'est pas
valable alors c'est pas un métier je
sais pas un pull-over il faudrait le
vendre au moins 1000 francs
[Musique]
pour que vous travaillez toujours avec
des vieux fer parce que vous verrez les
trucs c'est pas bon pour nous pourquoi
parce que on peut pas faire des choses
brodées avec
vous faites ce métier depuis combien de
temps et puis il a fait deux ans et demi
j'en ai 82 alors on est quand même
vous trouvez pas ça bizarre que votre
matériel de travail de tous les jours
soit dans un musée
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
métier qui peut renaître non
[Musique]
j'ai construit ma maison mais je lui dis
maintenant c'est totalement différent
même qu'il y a Le Fur et Cher vous voyez
plus de temps
c'est fini puisque autrefois
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui l'artisanat vous savez
c'est très bien les entreprises
artisanales importantes et pour
rentabiliser une entreprise une
nécessaire d'avoir donc un volant de
clientèle et ses activités
malheureusement sont maintenant un peu
dépassés
on est plutôt cellier parce que
maintenant il m'a réveillé quoi c'était
l'appellation
aussi bien de l'équitation que des sacs
cuirs que des serviettes d'écoliers que
de la garniture on est obligé et de la
réparation
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
métier qui est de l'avenir l'avenir
c'est difficile à dire vous savez
maintenant on peut pas dire pour
l'instant bon on a un travail à peu près
normal mais pour savoir si ça va
continuer c'est autre chose et vous vous
avez appris le métier comment j'ai fait
mon apprentissage chez mon père et puis
j'étais à l'extérieur également aussi un
petit peu est-ce que vous prenez des
apprentis
pour prendre des apprentis puis
d'ailleurs faut trouver
il y a personne qui vient vous demander
et vous êtes vous êtes le seul sur Dijon
vous appreniez le métier à quelqu'un
sur la place du travail pour ces
personnes
alors nous sommes nous sommes très
prudents justement pour engager les gens
dans ces petits métiers parce que à
partir du moment que la personne
s'installe pour nous enfin elle crée une
entreprise même si le travail seul et
une entreprise et il y a toute une série
de charges qui vont qui se sentent bien
découlent alors il faut il faut que les
gens soient bien conscients que
il faut avoir le marché et essayer de
trouver le marché de quartier j'ai accès
ma politique je préfère prendre beaucoup
moins cher chez chaque client mais avoir
pratiquement cet été clientèle de
quartier ce que j'ai obtenu à l'heure
actuelle il y a un problème aussi au
point de vue artisanal c'est que on peut
dire sur Dijon en point de vue nettoyage
pratiquement 80% de la clientèle de
nettoyage est obtenu par quatre grosses
maisons combien vous gagnez en moyenne à
l'heure actuelle après pratiquement 300
d'activité mon chiffre d'affaires
mensuel se situe aux alentours de 10000
francs sur ces 10000 francs par mois
plus de chargé déduites chargés sociales
impôts etc il me reste pratiquement la
moitié à savoir 5000 francs par mois en
plus parce que vous reconnaître que les
entreprises de main d'eux ils ont prises
l'artisanat sont pénalisés par rapport à
la fabrication industrielle et la
fabrication mécanique et là c'est une
des réformes que l'on souhaite voir
aboutir au niveau des charges sociales
une réforme complète du système social
et non plus basé
les charges sur sur la main d'oeuvre sur
le revenu mais prendre d'autres éléments
considérations vous gagnez votre vie à
une position pour faire du travail il
faut faire du travail dans cette branche
il faut faire des heures il y a pas de
secret moi tous les matins à 5h15 tous
les matins je suis sur mes chantiers et
quelques fois je finis à 8 heures 9
heures il m'arrive de travailler le
samedi dimanche et
vous vous travaillez
toute la l'été je suis au lac pour
profiter des estivants et l'hiver je
reviens ici on gagne pas des millions
mon gars il y a on gagne sa vie quoi
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez avant j'étais
représentant
c'est un copain qui qui était pizzaïolo
dans une pizza alors il m'a montré et il
est venu passer plusieurs jours avec moi
et puis il m'a montré quoi
voilà alors
[Musique]
de nouveau petit métier se crée c'est
l'imagination au pouvoir face au chômage
mais entre les anciens qui disparaissent
les nouveaux qui s'inventent il y a un
écart considérable celui de la
décalification les premiers ça prenaient
pendant des années les seconds
s'improvisent presque ne requiert qu'un
investissement minime et ne nourrissent
pas une famille pendant toute une vie
[Musique]
voilà c'est parti circuit de
l'investissement du four faut compter si
je l'achète dans le commerce et vous
vendez à peu près 10000 francs amis
alors que là c'est moi qui l'ai fait
avec mon père on en a eu juste l'achat
du matériel et c'est une quoi la main
d'oeuvre on la prend pas parce que c'est
nous qui l'avons est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de faire ça toute votre vie
non non
[Musique]
un restaurant oui quelque chose comme ça
symbole d'espoir le maréchal ferrant il
pratique ce qu'il considère comme le
plus beau métier du monde sa forge et
ses outils dans une camionnette il se
déplace chez les clients dans un rayon
de 40 km nous l'avons rencontré dans un
cercle hippique
mon grand-père était déjà mort Richard
mon père avait été et j'ai pris la suite
j'ai suivi le métier de père en fils
[Musique]
on a tourné pendant pas mal de temps et
il est arrivé une période où il y avait
pratiquement plus de chevaux alors je
m'étais recyclé
j'étais rentré en usine pendant une
douzaine d'années et
ma foi un jour en discutant avec un
vétérinaire on discuter métier branche
de métier et le vétérinaire quand il a
su que j'étais maréchal-ferrant
m'a demandé pourquoi que j'avais laissé
tomber le métier alors j'ai dit tout
simplement il y a pratiquement plus de
chevaux je ne pourrais pas vivre avec le
métier de maréchal-ferrant alors il m'a
demandé de reprendre les outils et de
qu'il arriverait à me refaire une
clientèle j'ai travaillé pendant pas mal
de temps en deux activités c'est à dire
que je travaillais en usine tout en
travaillant le métier de Marie en
faisant le métier de maréchal-ferrant
mais
j'en avais assez de travailler en usine
alors que le métier de maréchal ferrant
c'était ma vie c'était ma passion alors
quand j'ai vu une clientèle assez
importante je j'ai eu à choisir et j'ai
préféré bien sûr le métier de
maréchal-ferrant qui est on est à l'air
on est au contact de l'animal contact de
la clientèle et ma foi je préfère à
toute autre chose
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
métier qui a un avenir pour vos enfants
je pense que mon garçon serait intéressé
par la suite et est-ce qu'il aura des
clients je pense que si la prendre le
métier avec vous comme je l'ai appris je
pense qu'il aura quand même une
clientèle valable c'est pas un métier
qui va mourir je ne pense pas je pense
que c'est un métier qui prendra de
plutôt de l'évolution
[Musique]